ممنوع استخدام كلمه جيم يجب استخدام كلمه
فرينه
وممنوع استخدام كلمه ساندويتش يجب استخدام
كلمه بوتر هي بعض من الكلمات التي تتجاوز
المئه المستعاره من اللغه الانجليزيه
وتستخدم في اللغه الروسيه والتي سيمنع
تداولها من الان وصاعدا وسيتم استبدالها
بمثيل لها من اللغه الروسيه بعد توقيع
الرئيس الروسي قانونا يمنع استخدام
الكلمات الاجنبيه في اللغه الروسيه
لحمايتها
بالفعل بدانا نلاحظ خلال سنوات الاخيره
توجها نحو استخدام كلمات مستعاره بكثره
والموجوده باللغه الروسيه تتسلل ايضا في
لغه الاعلام على سبيل المثال تزعجني جدا
كلمه لوك مظهر بدل استخدامها باللغه الاصل
الروسيه اوبراز
[موسيقى]
القانون الجديد لن يحظر استخدام الكلمات
الاجنبيه في المؤسسات التعليميه وقطاع
الخدمات والمراسلات الرسميه لمؤسسات
الدوله فقط بل في السينما والاعلانات
التجاريه ووسائل الاعلام وخلال الخطابات
الرسميه التي يلقيها المسؤولون
والدبلوماسيون الروس ايضا
يصانع القانون والهيئات التنفيذيه في
روسيا سيحتاجون لبعض الوقت للعمل على بعض
النقاط التي قد تشكل صعوبه في هذا الصدد
اما من ناحيه تحمل المسؤوليه فهنا يجب
البدء من الدستور كما ان اللجنه المتخصصه
للغه الروسيه ستلعب دورا في هذه المساله
اوكي اقوى
الان تحديد ما هي الكلمات التي فعلا تعتبر
روسيه
القانون لن يدخل حيز التنفيذ بشكل كامل
الا في غضون عامين بعد ان يتم تجميع
القواميس والكتب والمراجع الخاصه التي
تحدد معايير اللغه الادبيه الروسيه
الحديثه ليتم العمل وفقها وسط تساؤلات عن
مدى امكانيه فرض غرامه في حال عدم
الالتزام بالقانون الجديد كانت طعم
العربيه موسكو